This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，这是走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. On the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字TWO。在Iheart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。听女性朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方。在《回顾过去》（The Look Back at it）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that. you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难中学到的一切》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着。你需要这么做。在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难中学到的一切》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父，但这次怀孕
appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychologies. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another highly requested episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. So guys, today we're going to talk about borderline personality disorder or BPD. Maybe you have seen the term thrown around online, especially recently. Maybe you've been, have seen it used to describe people who others think are manipulative or dramatic or even dangerous without really even knowing the whole story or what BPD actually means. Maybe for some of you listening, you know, this is a term that you've encountered more personally. Maybe this is a diagnosis that you've received. Maybe you grew up with a parent who had BBT and didn't really understand it until recently. Or maybe you are hearing it for the very first time on the...
大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听另一个呼声极高的单集，我们将剖析20多岁的心理。所以伙计们，今天我们要讨论的是边缘型人格障碍或BPD。也许你在网上看到过这个词，尤其是最近。也许你看到有人用它来形容那些别人认为爱操纵人、戏剧化甚至危险的人，而根本没有了解全部的故事或者BPD真正的含义。也许对于你们中的一些听众来说，你知道，这是一个你更亲密接触过的词。也许这是一个你收到的诊断。也许你从小和有BBT的父母一起长大，直到最近才真正理解它。或者你可能是第一次听到这个词...
this podcast. What I really want to do today is give a proper and real introduction into the world of people with BPD into what this condition actually means and probably more importantly, what it doesn't, because I think as is the case with a lot of mental health disorders or personality disorders, the truth gets rather twisted and I think it gets made smaller until it becomes a bit of a stereotype. This has definitely happened with borderline personality disorder. At its heart, this is a condition, this is a disorder of emotional regulation and attachment, meaning it massively affects how someone feels, their mood, their relationships,
这个播客。我今天真正想做的是对BPD患者的世界进行一次恰当且真实的介绍，介绍这种状况究竟意味着什么，可能更重要的是，它不意味着什么，因为我认为就像许多心理健康障碍或人格障碍一样，真相被扭曲了，我认为它被缩小了，直到它变成了一种刻板印象。边缘型人格障碍肯定发生过这种情况。在其核心，这是一种情况，这是一种情绪调节和依恋的障碍，这意味着它极大地影响了某人的感受、他们的情绪、他们的关系，
how they see themselves, how they view love, one of our core human experiences. Some of the ways that I've seen people describe it is basically like a lack of of identity. You get such intense feelings of anger and nihilism that you feel completely empty and then the next day or the next minute, you will be filled with like such an intense, ecstatic joy that you feel like the world could never be an evil place again. It's scary kind of not knowing how you feel about the same situation and therefore kind of not knowing who you are. Others have also described this emotional pendulum by saying it's like having so much emotion that you don't know what to do with it, but also at the same time, feeling so empty and having
他们如何看待自己，他们如何看待爱，我们人类的核心体验之一。我看到人们描述它的一些方式基本上就像是缺乏同一性。你会产生如此强烈的情绪愤怒和虚无主义，以至于你觉得自己完全空虚，然后第二天或下一分钟，你就会充满如此强烈、狂喜的快乐，以至于你觉得这个世界再也不可能是个邪恶的地方了。对于同一情况不知道自己作何感想，因此不知道自己是谁，这种感觉有点吓人。其他人也通过这样描述这个情感钟摆：它就像拥有太多的情绪，以至于你不知道该拿它们怎么办，但与此同时，又感到如此空虚，并且拥有
both of these things exist at the same time. You can go from loving a person so deeply you think, you know, you might die and then suddenly hating everything about them. It is the disorder, it is a roller coaster disorder. That's really like the best way to put it. And what actually is behind this emotional intensity. Because I think you may know the symptoms, you may know the general character profile of what people assume people with BPD look like. But do we really know the origins? Do we know how this disorder impacts the mind? Why it is so linked to attachment? I think a lot of people don't. So I really want to talk about it today. I really want to reduce a little bit of the stigma and just talk about some probably unknown facts and some unknown research about BPD that you might not see presented on TikTok and that you might not see in everyday discussions about this condition.
这两件事同时存在。你可以从深爱一个人到觉得自己可能会死，然后突然讨厌他的一切。它是这种障碍，它是一种过山车式的障碍。这真的是最好的表达方式。这种情感强度背后的真正原因是什么。因为我想你可能知道症状，你可能知道大家对BPD患者长相的一般性格画像。但我们真的知道起源吗？我们知道这种障碍是如何影响大脑的吗？为什么它与依恋有如此紧密的联系？我想很多人并不知道。所以我今天真的很想谈谈它。我真的很想减少一点耻辱感，只谈论一些你可能在TikTok上看不到的，并且你可能在关于这种状况的日常讨论中看不到的关于BPD的未知事实和一些未知研究。
As always, I say this every time with these specific episodes that we do on mental health disorders, this is not a diagnostic tool. It's not a diagnostic tool for yourself or to be used for someone else. nor is it a substitute for therapy or real life intervention. We're also going to be talking about some sensitive topics today to do with suicide, suicidal ideation and self-harm. So if that's something that you are sensitive towards, just consider whether this episode is what you need to hear today. It will be here in a month.
和往常一样，每次针对我们关于心理健康障碍的具体单集，我都会这么说，这不是一个诊断工具。它不是你自己或用于其他人的诊断工具。它也不能替代治疗或现实生活中的干预。今天我们还将讨论一些与自杀、自杀意念和自残相关的敏感话题。所以如果这是你比较敏感的话题，请考虑这一集是否是你今天需要听到的。它一个月后还在这里。
It will be here in a year. You can always come back to it when you feel more prepared. I will leave you some links in the description for further resources. So if you or someone you know may be experiencing borderline, if you think they may be experiencing borderline, if this episode has left you distressed, hopefully those help you find the help that you need in your local area and for what you're going through. So I just want to give that little disclaimer before we get into it. It probably will be a more heavy episode than we're used to. But take care of yourself. And without further ado, let's dive into the psychology of borderline personality.
它一年后还在这里。当你觉得准备更充分时，你随时可以回来。我会在简介中留下一些链接，提供更多资源。因此，如果你或你认识的人可能正在经历边缘型人格，如果你认为他们可能正在经历边缘型人格，如果这一集让你感到痛苦，希望这些能帮助你在当地找到你需要的帮助，以及应对你正在经历的事情。所以在我们深入探讨之前，我只想做这个小小的声明。这可能比我们习惯的单集要沉重一些。但要照顾好自己。闲话少说，让我们深入探讨边缘型人格的心理学。
order. So I want to begin with a little bit of like an imagination exercise to really get across even just a small part of the experience of someone with BPD. This is how people describe it. Imagine for a moment that every emotion that you have felt today or in the last week you are currently feeling right now all at the same time. You know, you don't just feel happy. You You feel a static joy. You don't just feel sadness. You feel bottomless despair. Every moment of rage, every moment of laughter, every moment of hatred from the past week of your life, you're experiencing it right now.
秩序。所以我想从一个小小的想象练习开始，真正传达哪怕一小部分BPD患者的体验。这就是人们描述它的方式。想象一下，你今天或过去一周感受到的每一种情绪，你现在正同时感受到所有这些情绪。你知道，你不仅感到快乐。你感受到的是狂喜。你不仅感到悲伤。你感受到的是无底的绝望。过去一周生活中的每一个愤怒时刻，每一个大笑时刻，每一个仇恨时刻，你现在都在经历。
These visceral emotions that I think are only usually available to us for a tiny portion of our lives and of our days, people with BPD, they feel them all the time. They feel them much more often in much, much higher definition. Now, imagine that these emotions get split into positive and negative. And now, instead of just feeling all your emotions at once, you're feeling all or nothing. You're feeling either entirely good and loved and happy or entirely miserable and depressed and angry. and that rapid, effective or emotional instability can be triggered by something that many of us would consider really, really tiny, really minuscule, you know, a delayed reply to a text message, a certain facial expression, a certain slight or perceived rejection. Not only is the depth of feeling amplified for people with BPD, and there have been studies that have shown that people, people who have borderline personality disorder may actually have access to a more nuanced emotional
这些本能的情绪，我认为通常只在我们生活和日子的很小一部分中对我们开放，而BPD患者，他们一直都在感受到这些。他们以更高的清晰度，更频繁地感受到这些。现在，想象一下这些情绪被分成积极的和消极的。现在，你不再是同时感受你所有的情绪，而是感受全或无。你要么完全感到美好、被爱和快乐，要么完全感到痛苦、沮丧和愤怒。这种快速、有效或情绪的不稳定可能会被我们许多人认为非常非常微小、非常微不足道的事情所触发，你知道的，对短信的延迟回复，某个面部表情，某种轻慢或感知到的拒绝。对于BPD患者来说，不仅这种感受的深度被放大了，而且有研究表明，边缘型人格障碍患者实际上可能能够接触到更细微的情绪
scale, but the rate at which these emotions is changing within someone with borderline personality disorder is also accelerated. This is what people often mean when they describe BPD as emotional instability. And in fact, that's exactly what some diagnostic manuals call it. This is a really important caveat before we get any further in the episode, if you are listening from somewhere outside of Australia or outside of the US, you might know borderline personality disorder as something entirely different. In the UK, in parts of Europe, in parts of Asia, you might hear the term emotionally unstable personality disorder or EUPD rather than borderline personality disorder. Now, the reason I'm going to go with BPD for this episode is, obviously, I am.
规模，但边缘型人格障碍患者体内这些情绪变化的速率也在加快。这就是人们在将BPD描述为情绪不稳定时经常的意思。事实上，这正是某些诊断手册所称呼它的方式。在我们进入本集的更深入内容之前，这是一个非常重要的警示，如果你是从澳大利亚或美国以外的地方收听的，你可能会对边缘型人格障碍有完全不同的了解。在英国、欧洲部分地区、亚洲部分地区，你可能会听到情感不稳定人格障碍（EUPD）这个词，而不是边缘型人格障碍。现在，我之所以在本集坚持使用BPD，很显然，我是
in Australia, and if you couldn't tell from my voice, but also it is the term that is used by the DSM, which we've spoken about before. Many times on the podcast, it is the diagnostic statistical manual of basically every single mental disorder known and categorized. So, you know, if I was to start saying emotionally unstable personality disorder,
在澳大利亚，如果你从我的声音中听不出来的话，而且这也是DSM使用的术语，我们之前已经讨论过好多次了。在播客中很多次，它是基本上所有已知和分类的精神障碍的诊断与统计手册。所以，你知道，如果我开始说情感不稳定人格障碍，
instead of borderline personality disorder, I think I would kind of slip up. So you may have heard this as a different, term in a different way, they do mean the same things. There is a reason, though, that they are labeled differently. The term or the preface of borderline comes from kind of an older way of thinking. Back in the day, clinicians believe that people with BPD with this condition were on the borderline between psychosis and neurosis.
而不是边缘型人格障碍，我想我可能会说漏嘴。所以你可能在不同的地方以不同的方式听到过这个词，它们的意思确实是一样的。不过，它们被贴上不同的标签是有原因的。边缘（borderline）这个术语或前缀来自一种较旧的思考方式。过去，临床医生认为患有BPD这种状况的人处于精神病和神经症的边缘。
Neurosis is also known as anxiety. Today, most experts agree that that is not actually what's happening. That description is outdated. We don't really use terms like neurosis anymore. Emotionally unstable, I should say, gets closer to the reality. What is really happening with this disorder is a nervous system that has been caused or forced to react intensely and unpredictably to emotional triggers. Let's talk about prevalence here for a little bit. BPD is estimated to be prevalent in anywhere between 0.7 to 5.8% of the general population.
神经症也被称为焦虑症。今天，大多数专家都同意这实际上并不是正在发生的事情。这种描述已经过时了。我们不再真正使用神经症这样的词。我应该说，情绪不稳定更接近现实。这种障碍真正发生的是一个神经系统，它被导致或被迫对情绪触发因素做出强烈且不可预测的反应。让我们在这里谈谈患病率。据估计，在普通人群中，BPD的患病率在0.7%到5.8%之间。
Ubers specific numbers right there. And I'll tell you why those numbers are so specific. They're so specific because that is the minimum and the maximum that researchers believe this condition could be present when considering factors like a lack of diagnosis, especially in certain population groups like men or in certain countries with underdeveloped mental health systems where there isn't as much, I guess, like, knowledge of this or opportunities for diagnosis.
这里有超具体的数字。我会告诉你为什么这些数字如此具体。它们之所以如此具体，是因为那是研究人员认为在考虑缺乏诊断等因素时，这种疾病可能存在的最小值和最大值，特别是在某些人群中，如男性，或者在心理健康系统欠发达的某些国家，那里可能没有那么多，我猜，比如，对这方面的了解或诊断的机会。
They're also considering if there is an over-representation. So sometimes when people try and find these estimates of like how common is a disorder in the world, they like to go as small as possible and as big as possible. So when you hear 5.8%, I don't want you to think that any time you go into work, anytime you're walking down the street, one and every 20 people have borderline personality disorder. Again, it's just like the max of all maxes. Now, let's talk about more deeply. Let's talk about what this disorder actually contains.
他们还在考虑是否存在过度代表。所以有时当人们试图寻找这些估计，比如世界上有多大比例的人患有某种障碍时，他们喜欢把范围设得尽可能小，尽可能大。所以当你听到5.8%时，我不想让你觉得任何时候你去上班，任何时候你走在街上，每20个人里就有一个人患有边缘型人格障碍。再说一次，这就像是极限中的极限。现在，让我们更深入地谈谈。让我们谈谈这种障碍实际上包含什么。
What are the hallmark symptoms of BPD? So, according to the DSM-5, if you want to be diagnosed with borderline personality disorder, a couple of things have to be true. Firstly, you have to experience a certain number of the following symptoms. An intense fear of abandonment. Unstable relationships and unstable self-image. So feeling amazing one minute. Terrible the next.
BPD的标志性症状是什么？因此，根据《精神疾病诊断与统计手册第五版》（DSM-5），如果你想被诊断为边缘型人格障碍，有几点必须成立。首先，你必须经历以下一定数量的症状。强烈的被抛弃恐惧。不稳定的关系和不稳定的自我形象。所以这一分钟感觉好极了。下一分钟感觉糟透了。
Impulsivity. Recurrent suicidal behavior or self-harm. Emotional instability. Rapid intense mood changes. Chronic feelings of emptiness. Intense anger inappropriate to the situation. and at the extreme stress-related paranoia or dissociation. I think that as of today, as of right now, as I'm recording this,
冲动。反复出现的自杀行为或自残。情绪不稳定。快速强烈的情绪变化。慢性的空虚感。与情况不相称的强烈愤怒。以及极端情况下与压力相关的偏执或解离。我认为截至今天，截至目前，在我录制这段音频的时候，
you need to have five or more of these symptoms present over a significant period of time and across various contexts. So you can't just feel emptiness, impulsivity, and intense rage when you're around your family and your family only. Or you can't just experience that when you're at the job, you hate. It has to be something that, unfortunately, isn't purely environmental or context-based, but which sits with you throughout all social, physical, emotional context. That is kind of the hurdle that you have to jump over to be diagnosed with BPD. We're going to talk about a couple of the
在相当长的一段时间内，并且在各种不同的语境下，你需要表现出其中五种或更多的症状。所以你不能仅仅在和你的家人在一起且仅仅和家人在一起时才感到空虚、冲动和强烈的愤怒。或者你不能仅仅在你讨厌的工作岗位上才经历这些。这必须是某种不幸地并非纯粹由环境或情境决定，而是伴随你度过所有社交、身体和情感情境的事情。这就是你为了被诊断为BPD而必须跨越的某种门槛。我们要讨论其中的几个
other hurdles later on. Don't worry. We'll get to it. So clearly when we talk about instability, this isn't just having a few mood swings. These swings are full body. They affect identity, relationships. They affect our relationship with ourselves, even sometimes how we see reality. One of the most devastating aspects of BPD is the way that it heightens risk for self-harm and suicide.
稍后的其他障碍。别担心。我们会讲到的。很显然，当我们谈论不稳定时，这不仅仅是经历几次情绪起伏。这些起伏是全身心的。它们会影响身份认同、人际关系。它们会影响我们与自己的关系，有时甚至会影响我们看待现实的方式。BPD最具毁灭性的方面之一是它加剧了自残和自杀风险的方式。
And this is kind of a known, very sad, secret of the community of people who endure and suffer from this condition. I saw this statistic the other day that as many as 70% I believe of those with BPD will attempt suicide at some point in their lifetime. That makes borderline personality disorder one if not the most high risk psychiatric diagnosis when it comes to mortality. I would assume it would be second only to anorexia. That statistic isn't necessarily meant to shock you, although it definitely shocked me. 70% is a ridiculously high number, but it's meant to just highlight how intense and painful this disorder can be for those who are living with it, whereby the only response,
这也是那些忍受和遭受这种疾病折磨的群体中一个众所周知的、非常悲伤的秘密。我前几天看到这样一个统计数据：我相信高达70%的BPD患者在其一生中的某个时刻会尝试自杀。这使得边缘型人格障碍成为在死亡率方面风险最高（如果不是最高的话）的精神科诊断之一。我猜它仅次于厌食症。这个统计数据并不一定是为了震惊你，尽管它绝对震惊了我。70%是一个荒谬的高数字，但它旨在强调这种障碍对于那些带着它生活的人来说是多么强烈和痛苦，以至于唯一的反应，
many of the people who are enduring this condition believe they can have. The only appropriate response is a drastic, devastating and permanent one. Another key complexity to do with BPD is that it actually rarely exists alone. We talked about those hurdles you need to get across. This is the second biggest hurdle. Getting the diagnosis is actually quite difficult because for someone with BPD, it is highly likely, in fact, it is more probable than not that they will also be experiencing another co-occurring mental health condition. The research in this is a little inconsistent, but in terms of the rate of co-occurrence with other mental health conditions, anywhere between 63 to 95% of people with borderline personality disorder
许多正在忍受这种状况的人相信他们可以做出反应。唯一恰当的反应是激烈的、毁灭性的和永久性的反应。与BPD相关的另一个关键复杂性是它实际上很少单独存在。我们讨论过你需要跨越的那些障碍。这是第二大障碍。获得诊断实际上相当困难，因为对于BPD患者来说，极有可能的是，事实上，更有可能的是，他们同时还在经历另一种共患的精神健康状况。对此的研究有些不一致，但就与其他精神健康状况的共患率而言，63%到95%的边缘型人格障碍患者
will also have another diagnosis at the time of their diagnosis. Now, that number, the 63 to 95%, that was found in a very well-me, known, 2019 Swedish population study, which looked at almost 2 million people with BPD. So I think that we can say that number is fairly accurate. Two million
在他们被诊断时也会有另一个诊断。现在，这个数字，63%到95%，是在一项非常知名、著名的2019年瑞典人口研究中发现的，该研究调查了近200万BPD患者。所以我认为我们可以说这个数字相当准确。两百万
people. I think that is the largest sample size of any study we have ever mentioned on the podcast before ever. Some of the most common co-occurring conditions are the ones that are obviously most common in society in general, so depression. anxiety disorders, bipolar disorder, but then also PTSD, complex PTSD, as it's called for short, substance use disorders and eating disorders. This one especially, eating disorders and BPD are incredibly
人。我认为这是我们在播客中提到过的有史以来任何研究中样本量最大的一次。一些最常见的共患状况显然是社会上最常见的状况，比如抑郁症、焦虑症、双相情感障碍，还有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、复杂性创伤后应激障碍（简称CPTSD）、物质使用障碍和进食障碍。特别是这一种，进食障碍和BPD是非常
common, especially bulimia and binge eating disorder. Now this overlap obviously can make things quite tricky. Imagine going into a doctor's office and, you know, really all your symptoms are coming from a large tumour. But instead of treating the tumour, they start treating a gash on your leg and they start treating you for a vitamin deficiency and they start treating, they send you to the dentist to get like dental treatment. And all along you have this big tumor that all of this stuff is coming from. Like that's how some people describe BPD. It's like you're treating you go into, I don't know, the medical system, specifically the mental health system, and you have this big thing that is really bothering you that you can't figure out.
常见的，尤其是贪食症和暴食症。现在这种重叠显然会让事情变得相当棘手。想象一下走进医生的办公室，你知道，其实你所有的症状都来自于一个大型肿瘤。但他们没有治疗肿瘤，而是开始治疗你腿上的一个伤口，开始治疗你的维生素缺乏症，开始治疗，把你送到牙医那里去做牙齿治疗。而一直以来你都有这个大肿瘤，所有这些问题都是由此产生的。就像有些人描述BPD的方式一样。这就像你去，我不知道，医疗系统，特别是心理健康系统，你有一个真正困扰你却找不出原因的大问题。
And as in order to get a final diagnosis, all these other little things get treated or get labeled first, when the big thing kind of goes undetected. I've heard so many stories of this from listeners of people who, you know, they had not even heard of the term BPD until they were in an impatient treatment for an eating disorder five years after they first developed said eating disorder or they've been treated for depression and anxiety for years before suddenly someone sits down and says you might have this
为了得到最终的诊断，所有这些其他的小事情首先得到了治疗或被贴上了标签，而那个大问题却在某种程度上未被发现。我从听众那里听到过很多这样的故事，他们甚至从未听说过BPD这个词，直到他们在因进食障碍接受住院治疗时，距离他们首次患上该进食障碍已经过去了五年，或者他们多年来一直因抑郁和焦虑接受治疗，突然有人坐下来对你说，你可能得了这个病。
and it's like the key that unlocks the door. I think that's similar for, you know, late stage diagnosis for ADHD and for autism. Often people don't get the label that they need and that they would really give them an answer until a little bit later in life. So where does BPD actually come from? Psychologists, researchers, they will often turn to the biosocial model to explain the origins of BPD. Now, the bio social model was originally proposed by Marsha Lyman in the 90s, I think,
这就好比是打开锁的钥匙。我认为这与晚期诊断ADHD和自闭症的情况类似。通常人们直到生命的晚期才得到他们需要的、真正能给他们答案的标签。那么BPD究竟从何而来？心理学家、研究人员通常会转向生物社会模型来解释BPD的起源。现在，生物社会模型最初是由玛莎·莱曼（Marsha Linehan）在90年代提出的，我想，
and she also is the creator of dialectical behavior therapy, DBT, which you have probably heard about on the podcast before. We're going to circle back to that in a second. But according to this biosocial model, BPD develops from a combination of a couple of things, almost like a perfect storm. It is not a singular thing that creates it. Firstly, there must be a biological vulnerability, meaning a person is born, naturally born with a heightened emotional sensitivity,
她也是辩证行为疗法（DBT）的创造者，你可能在之前的播客中听说过这个疗法。我们稍后会回过头来讨论这一点。但根据这个生物社会模型，BPD是由多种因素结合发展的，几乎就像是一场完美风暴。不是单一的事物创造了它。首先，必须存在生物学易感性，这意味着一个人天生就对情感高度敏感，
a certain specific kind of temperament or heightened emotional dysregulation. An individual basically is seen in this case to have had a predisposition for either hyperarousal or hyperactivity. So their nervous system reacts more strongly to emotional stimuli and takes longer to return to a baseline because of their genetic blueprint. It has nothing to do with environment yet. There's a lot of different theories and pieces of research. looking at the specific biological basis behind this hyperarousal or hyperreactivity. And what a lot of people typically come back to is this one structure in our brain, one of the
某种特定的气质或高度的情绪失调。在这种情况下，基本上被认为具有对过度唤醒或过度反应的倾向。因此，由于他们的遗传蓝图，他们的神经系统对情感刺激的反应更强烈，并且需要更长的时间才能恢复到基线水平。这与环境还没有任何关系。有许多不同的理论和研究。着眼于这种过度唤醒或过度反应背后的具体生物学基础。很多人通常会回到的就是我们大脑中的这一个结构，其中最小的结构之一，也就是杏仁核。现在，杏仁核恰好位于我们称之为旧大脑的中心。它负责检测威胁并触发情绪反应，比如恐惧或愤怒，这反过来也会触发身体反应。现在，在BPD患者身上，当对这些患者的大脑进行fMRI扫描时，他们倾向于发现杏仁核过度活跃，这意味着当一个相当无处不在的或微小的情绪体验发生时，与所谓的（我讨厌这么说）所谓的正常大脑或对照大脑相比，它会以不成比例的方式做出反应。在这种情况下，大脑的警报系统会在出现拒绝或批评的微小迹象时响起，因为它无法区分需要2%反应的事物和需要200%反应的事物。这就是这种障碍背后的强度的一部分。
smallest structures, which is the amygdala. Now, the amygdala sits right in the center of what we call our old brain. It is responsible for detecting threats and for triggering an emotional response like fear or anger, which will in turn also trigger a physical response. Now, in people with BPD, when they do fMRI scans of these people's brains, what they tend to find is that the amygdala is hyperactive, meaning that when a rather ubiquitous or small emotionally experience occurs, it reacts in a disproportionate way compared to a so-called, and I hate saying this, a so-called normal brain or a control brain. The brain's alarm system in this case goes off the slightest sign of rejection or criticism because it cannot distinguish between something that requires a 2% reaction and a 200% reaction. That is part of the intensity behind this disorder.
现在在另一边，我们有前额叶皮层。现在，前额叶皮层和杏仁核经常被一起讨论，因为它们就像，我该怎么形容呢？它们就像平衡木的两端。前额叶皮层，她是逻辑，她是调节，她是提供理性、执行功能并帮助我们冷静下来的东西。现在，如果杏仁核显示出高度活跃，前额叶在BPD患者身上则显示出降低的活动或降低的连通性。
Now on the other side, we have the prefrontal cortex. Now, the prefrontal cortex and the amygdala often get talked about together a lot because they are like, how do I describe it? They're like on two sides of the balance beam. The prefrontal cortex, she is logic, she is regulation, she is the thing that provides reason, executive functioning, and helps calm us down. Now, if the amygdala shows hindry activity, the frontal lobe shows reduced activity or reduced connectivity in people with BPD.
基本上，有更少的道路，更少的高速通路绕着前额叶运行，所以传递的信息有点慢。所以你拥有这样一个大脑：情绪加速器格外敏感，而刹车系统反应较慢/不太管用。对任何人来说，这都是一个很难控制的心智。当然，这确实具有遗传成分。如果你有一个患有BPD的父母，如果你有一个兄弟姐妹，如果你有一个患有BPD的直系亲属，
Basically, there are less roads, less fast pathways running around the frontal lobe, so messages are a little bit slower. So you've got a brain where the emotional accelerator is extra sensitive and the braking system is less responsive slash doesn't really work. That's a hard mind to control for anybody. Of course, this does have a genetic component. If you have a parent, if you have a sibling, if you have an immediate family member with BPD,
你随后患上这种障碍的几率在40%到60%之间。它具有大约40%到60%的遗传性。现在，很难分清这是因为你成长在一个有人患有某种导致他们极具两极分化和反应性的障碍的环境中，还是它纯粹是遗传的。我们能弄清楚这一点的最好方法是通过双胞胎研究。这里似乎确实既有遗传背景，也有环境背景。有家族成员或具有某种基因组或为BPD做好准备的特定基因等遗传方面的特征是，这种易感性实际上可以完全处于休眠状态
the chances of you then developing that disorder, sits around the 40 to 60% mark. It's about 40 to 60% heritable. Now it's kind of hard to detach whether it's because you've been raised in an environment where someone has a disorder that causes them to be quite polarizing and reactive or whether it is purely genetic. The best way we can figure it out is through twin studies. And it does seem to be that there is both the genetic and an environmental context here. The genetic aspect of having a family member or having a certain genome or whatever it is that has been primed for BPD is that that vulnerability can actually lay completely dormant
持续一个人的一生或很多很多年，直到有什么东西触发它。这就是我们谈到生物社会模型的第二部分的地方，即无效化环境的作用，这意味着许多后来患上BPD的人从小就生活在一个没有教他们如何管理情绪、没有为他们提供管理情绪的安全空间、并且在童年时期可能经历过非常严重和极端的事情的世界里，这些事情是他们无法理解的，他们无法控制，作为孩子，他们也没有得到支持去理解。
for somebody's whole life or for many, many years until something triggers it. and this is where we get to talk about the second part of the biosocial model, which is the role of an invalidating environment, meaning that a lot of people who go on to develop BPD from a young age probably existed in a world that didn't teach them how to manage their emotions, didn't give them a safe space to manage their emotions, and who probably experienced something very severe and extreme during their childhood, that they couldn't grasp, they couldn't control, they weren't supported to understand as a child.
从那时起，他们所有的情绪都达到了100级。你们都知道我有一个秘密癖好，那就是如果我在研究一集我想更多地了解生活经验的节目，我喜欢去Reddit浏览所有我猜类似支持板块的内容。在其中一个关于BPD的板块中，我发现很多人在讨论这种前后对比的体验，就像一个他们感觉到自己的大脑，这个新大脑，他们的BPD大脑，“开启”的时刻。这正是我们正在谈论的。存在生物学易感性，一个被环境体验突然“开启”的光控开关。现在，那可能会是什么
And so from that point on, all of their emotions were at level 100. You guys know my guilty secret is that if I'm researching an episode where I want to know more about lived experience, I love going into Reddit and reading through all like the, I guess like the support boards. and in one of the ones for BPD, I found a lot of people talking about this experience of a before and after, like a moment where they felt their brain, this new brain, their BPD brain, like switch on. And this is exactly what we're talking about. There's a biological vulnerability, a light switch that is suddenly switched on by an environmental experience. Now, what might that
环境体验呢，嗯，有很多选择，实际上有很多非常糟糕的选择，但它通常是创伤，无论是微妙的还是显而易见的，这增加了这些影响并创造了我们现在称之为边缘型或情绪不稳定的人格障碍或人格类型。2018年发表在《人格与心理健康杂志》（Journal for Personality and Mental Health）上的一项研究观察了13至17岁因BPD而在住院部接受治疗的青少年样本。然后，在这些患有BPD的儿童中，他们还将他们与没有BPD的同龄人样本以及另外290名患有BPD的成年住院患者进行了匹配。
environmental experience B, well, there are a lot of options, a lot of really actually terrible options, but it's often trauma, either subtle or overt, that adds to these effects and that creates the personality disorder or personality type we now call borderline or emotionally unstable. A 2018 study published in the Journal for Personality and Mental Health looked at a sample of of adolescents from 13 to 17 who were at an inpatient unit as a result of their BPD. And then of these people who, of these children who had BPD, they also matched them with a sample of people of the same age who didn't have BPD and then a further 290 adult in patients with BPD.
他们只是让每一个群体——患有BPD的青少年、没有BPD的青少年和患有BPD的成年人——回答几个关于他们童年的问题，特别是关于虐待或忽视的经历。该研究发现，患有BPD的青少年描述的虐待经历明显多于他们心理健康的同龄人。但他们往往以一种相当超脱的方式这样做。“哦，你知道，我真的不知道我为什么会这样，
And they just got every single group, the teenagers with BPD, the teenagers without BPD, and the adults with BPD to answer a few questions about their childhood, specifically experiences of abuse or neglect. What the study found was that adolescence with BPD described significantly more abusive experiences than their psychologically healthy peers. But often they did so in quite a detached way. Oh, you know, I don't really know why I'm like this,
但随后他们会继续解释一些绝对在心理上令人崩溃的事情。更有趣的是，对这些事件的回忆以及我猜那样的创伤率和情感或童年忽视率在成年组中也是非常相似的。许多这些人发现，他们童年逆境的影响在成年期甚至更加明显。这可能是由于早期创伤的长期影响，以及无法通过这些经历来调节自己的事实，这意味着这些经历的影响只是
but then they would go on to explain something that was just like absolutely psychologically crushing. What's even more interesting is that that recall of those events and I guess that rate of trauma and emotional or childhood neglect was very similar in the adult group as well. And a lot of these people found that the impact of their childhood adversity was almost more pronounced in adulthood. perhaps due to the prolonged effects of early trauma and the fact that the inability to regulate themselves through those experiences had meant that the impact of those experiences had just been
允许复合创伤，特别是当它是关系创伤时，与你的照顾者如何对待你有关，可能与家庭中的死亡有关，与社会拒绝或社会痛苦或悲伤有关，它也加剧了被抛弃的恐惧。这使得人际关系中的信任变得更加困难，并强化了对情绪压力的过度反应，这是BPD的另一个核心要素。现在，创伤不必是你能够指出、反思并说这就是它开始的那个巨大、重大的事情。
allowed to compound trauma, especially when it's relational trauma to do with how your caregivers treated you, to do with maybe a death in the family, to do with social rejection or social pain or grief, It also heightens a fear of abandonment. And it makes trust in relationships a lot more difficult. And it reinforces that hyperreactivity to emotional stress, which is another core element of BPD. Now, trauma doesn't have to be this huge, major thing that you can point to and reflect on and say this is where it began.
对于许多BPD患者来说，他们实际上说：“你知道，我的童年相当不错。”他们不记得有被虐待的童年。但正如我们之前所说，当你让他们描述时，那是身体在场的父母，他们把食物端上桌，但却极度冷漠。父母自己也患有BPD。因为那是孩子或这个人所知道的唯一的照顾和父母的爱，所以这对他们来说感觉很正常。或者只是没有被重视。环境根本无法匹配孩子的敏感度，在那里他们觉得自己太多余或太戏剧化，在那里他们觉得每次他们说“不要抛弃
For a lot of people with BPD, they actually say, you know, my childhood was pretty good. they don't recount having an abuse of childhood. But as we said before, when you ask them to describe it, it's parents who are physically present, who put food on the table, but are deeply dismissive. Parents who themselves had BPD. And because that's the only caregiving and parental love the child or the person has ever known, that felt normal to them. Or it's just not being valued. It's environments that just didn't match the child's sensitivity, where they felt like they were too much or too dramatic, where they felt like every time they said don't abandon
我”时，有人会或者有人会认为利用这些不安全感来玩弄很有趣。我们这里真正指出的是，创伤如何与生物学易感性相互作用，然后与情感无效化或环境无效化相互作用。这是在99%的情况下产生BPD的三位一体。正是它塑造了情绪调节、自我概念，当然还有我们的依恋模式。现在，考虑到这一点，我们将进行短暂的休息。但当我们回来时，让我们真正谈谈这如何影响我们的人际关系，因为我认为这是人们对BPD最好奇或通常第一次接触到BPD的地方。所以请继续收听。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，这是走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中。我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等进行对话，以超越在健康产业中占据主导地位的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上具有炎症性。
me, someone would or someone would think that it was funny to play into these insecurities. Really what we are pointing to here is how trauma interacts with biological vulnerability, which then interacts with emotional invalidation or environmental invalidation. That is the trifecta that creates BPD, and I would say 99% of cases. And it's what shapes emotional regulation, self-concept, and of course our attachment pattern. Now, with that in mind, we are going to take a short break. But when we return, let's really talk about how this impacts our relationships, because I think this is the space where people are most curious about BPD or often first
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字TWO PERCENT，在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方。
introduced to BPD. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA上双击小肯姆（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当侃爷（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at it）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的快克（crack）。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看到这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在还有艾滋病在桌面上，所以……谢谢你完成这句话。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
是的，我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。
including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence.
欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难中学到的一切》（Learn the Hardway），我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了那样东西，而我们仍在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候做得够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
因为你觉得在地球上时做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两种不同级别的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
有时我们在追求某事时，过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却仍在追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
是因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要吗？还是你因为害怕才做一个好人？因为这是两种不同的意图，兄弟。没错。这也是两个不同的信任层次。我希望你能真正成为一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，
is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. L. S. Correct? I doctored the test one.
我们将在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中真实探讨治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的诉讼战来证明真相。女士，你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespe and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这花了一大批互联网侦探才破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一种令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格里格·阿莱斯佩和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news. at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨戴尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻。马里科帕县劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. always saying that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
规则一，千万不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万不要惹她的朋友。总是说要相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女朋友们》这个新季中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎，所以她们自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女朋友》。相信我，宝贝。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。
Something really critical and key with BPD, as I mentioned before, is the role of relationships. They carry so much of the disorders weight. And a lot of the times, I think it is where BPD becomes most visible in everyday life, especially to others. if you have watched Girl Interrupted, Fatal Attraction, Silver Linings Playbook, these are like
关于边缘型人格障碍（BPD），正如我之前提到的，一个非常关键的核心是人际关系的作用。它们承载了该障碍很大一部分的重量。很多时候，我认为这也是 BPD 在日常生活中变得最明显的地方，尤其是对其他人而言。如果你看过《移魂女郎》、《致命吸引力》、《乌云背后的幸福线》，这些就像是
pop culture references that I actually think are pretty good at explaining or showing the intensity of this experience for people. I personally, I love Silver Linings Playbook. It is one of my all-time favorite movies, but if you've seen it, you will feel or you will notice that the movie
流行文化参考，我实际上认为它们在解释或展示人们这种体验的强烈程度方面相当不错。我个人非常喜欢《乌云背后的幸福线》。它是我有史以来最喜欢的电影之一，但如果你看过，你会感觉到或注意到这部电影
has this weird way of making you feel stressed and making you feel on edge, especially from the main character. Like, his interactions with people are so, they become so volatile at times. And you can feel that through the movie. And I apparently say, I don't have BPD, but I've been told it is a very good depiction of how this feels inside the mind of someone with BPD. Like things are rising, things are like just spiraling. And it's all joy in the next one moment and it's all.
有一种奇怪的方式让你感到压力和紧张，尤其是来自主角。比如，他与人的互动是如此，有时变得非常不稳定。你可以通过电影感受到这一点。我显然说过，我没有 BPD，但有人告诉我，这非常生动地描绘了 BPD 患者内心的感受。就像事情在升级，事情就像在螺旋式上升。这一刻全都是喜悦，下一刻全都是。
disappointment or anger or hate the next. Psychologists often frame this through the lens of, obviously, attachment theory. Many people with BPD show what's called an anxious preoccupied or a disorganized attachment style. That means that they desperately crave closeness and connection, but at the same time, that intimacy, because it is something their desire so much, feels deeply threatening. When closeness for them has so often been paired with pain, rejection, or inconsistency. Love becomes both the thing they need the most and the thing they fear the most. They fear the loss of that love. They fear that someone is just inevitably going to leave them and they fight very, very hard internally and externally
失望、愤怒或仇恨。心理学家通常通过显然是依恋理论的镜头来构建这一点。许多 BPD 患者表现出所谓的焦虑依恋型或混乱型依恋风格。这意味着他们拼命渴望亲密和联系，但与此同时，由于这种亲密感是他们如此渴望的东西，因此让人感到深深的威胁。当对他们来说，亲密感经常与痛苦、拒绝或不一致联系在一起时。爱既成为了他们最需要的东西，也成为了他们最害怕的东西。他们害怕失去那种爱。他们害怕某人不可避免地会离开他们，他们在内心和外部都进行了非常、非常激烈的抗争
to prevent that from happening. This plays out in what we sometimes call a push, pull dynamic. On one hand, they're craving this bond, they're craving intimacy, they are pulling it closer. And on the other hand, they're so fearful of being hurt that they push away. And that's what the withdrawal and the anger looks like. There's a very famous phrase used to describe this, which is, I hate you, please don't leave me. You've probably heard of it. It is actually the name of one of the most well-known books on BPD. And it's exactly as it sounds. I hate you, please don't leave me. I actually love you. What we sometimes realize is that love for them feels so intense,
以防止这种情况发生。这在有时被称为推拉动态的机制中表现出来。一方面，他们渴望这种纽带，渴望亲密，他们把这种纽带拉得更近。另一方面，他们又如此害怕受到伤害以至于把对方推开。这就是疏离和愤怒的表现形式。有一个非常著名的短语用来形容这一点，那就是：我恨你，请不要离开你。你可能听说过它。它实际上是关于 BPD 最著名的书之一的名字。它听起来就是那样。我恨你，请不要离开你。我其实爱你。我们有时意识到的是，对他们来说，爱感觉如此强烈，
that sometimes it just gets confused with all other intense emotions. Or you start to anticipate the pain of someone leaving before it happens. And so you're reacting or you are acting out, this future imagination that you have of how it's going to feel when this all comes to an end. relationships really do feel like, as they described, a pendulum swimming between extremes of idealizing one's partner and then devaluing them. At one moment, you know, your partner is perfect. They're the best thing that's ever happened to you. They are gorgeous and beautiful and kind and everything you've ever wanted. And the next, after some perceived slight or disappointment,
有时它只是与所有其他强烈的情感混淆了。或者你开始在痛苦发生之前就预料到有人离开的痛苦。所以你正在反应，或者你在演练，你对这一切结束时的感觉的未来想象。人际关系确实感觉像他们所描述的那样，像一个在理想化伴侣和贬低伴侣两个极端之间摆动的钟摆。在某一时刻，你知道，你的伴侣是完美的。他们是你遇到的最好的事情。他们华丽、美丽、善良，是你一直想要的一切。而在下一次，在受到某种感知到的轻视或失望之后，
that same partner might be seen as cruel or untrustworthy. And in that moment, it feels like you'd never want to see them. again. It's ruined. It's not that the person with BPD wants to see things in this black and white way. It's that their emotions are so overwhelming that it's hard to hold both the good and the bad in one mind at the same time. This has a name. It's known as splitting. And it's basically the inability to hold opposing thoughts, feelings or beliefs all at once. Obviously, no one is ever perfect. You know, even if someone is literally our soulmate, and the love of our life and we've managed to find them, things do go wrong. But for someone with BPD, often to survive the internal emotional volatility,
同一个伴侣可能会被视为残酷或不值得信任。在那一刻，感觉你再也不想见到他们了。一切都毁了。并不是 BPD 患者想以这种非黑即白的方式看待事情。而是他们的情绪如此汹涌，以至于很难同时在心中容纳好与坏。这有一个名字。它被称为分裂。这基本上是无法同时容纳相反的思想、感觉或信念。显然，没有人是完美的。你知道，即使某人真的是我们的灵魂伴侣，是我们生命中的挚爱，而且我们设法找到了他们，事情还是会出问题。但对于 BPD 患者来说，通常为了在内心的情感动荡中生存下来，
they do find it easier to make outright categorizations, like this person is evil or this person is an angel. And when someone sits in the middle, sits in the gray area, they cannot just be a normal person with flaws, with inconsistencies, with normal human reactions. That's what makes everyday relational conflict, disagreements, disagreements, so difficult for someone with this disorder.
他们确实发现做出明确的分类更容易，比如这个人是邪恶的或是这个天使。而当有人坐在中间，坐在灰色地带时，他们就不能只是一个有缺点、有不一致、有正常人类反应的普通人。这就是为什么日常的人际冲突、意见不合对患有这种障碍的人来说如此困难。
I read a few reports of what this felt like for people with BPD and what some people describe is this inability to detach the bad feeling about the situation from the person in the situation. Obviously, having arguments in a relationship is uncomfortable, but also there's this whole rupture and repair idea of you do need to sometimes have friction and conflict in order to build the muscle and build the volume of your relationship and to move forward. And so it's kind of
我读了一些关于 BPD 患者对此有何感受的报告，一些人描述的是无法将对情况的不良感觉与情况中的人脱钩。显然，在恋爱中争吵是不舒服的，但也有整个破裂和修复的概念，即你有时确实需要摩擦和冲突来建立肌肉并建立关系的体量并继续前进。所以这有点像
just a normal part of things. Even if it feels bad now, you can move forward. Someone with BPD sees that situation and is like, well, that's just all the evidence I need that this person is going to treat me poorly in the future, that our relationship is doomed. And so of course they react accordingly. They react defensively or from a place of pain. You know, you have this fight with a friend, right? It's heated. It's rough. It's hard. And if you have BPD, sometimes you might feel like afterwards, okay, well, that friendship is over, I guess. Like, that's, that's dumb. That person is a terrible person. They never want to see me again. So I'll be the first one and never want to see them again first, if that makes sense. And then three days later, you know, they'll text you wanting to grab a coffee
事情的正常部分。即使现在感觉不好，你也可以继续前进。BPD 患者看到这种情况就会想，这正是我需要的全部证据，证明这个人将来会对我不好，我们的关系注定要失败。所以他们当然会做出相应的反应。他们会进行防守反应或出于痛苦的立场。你知道，你和朋友吵了一架，对吧？气氛很激烈。很粗暴。很艰难。如果你有 BPD，有时你可能会在事后觉得，好吧，那段友谊结束了，我想。这太蠢了。那个人是个糟糕透顶的人。他们再也不想见到我了。所以我要做第一个也再也不想见到他们的人，如果这说得通的话。然后三天后，你知道，他们会发信息给你想喝杯咖啡
or wanting to hang out and talk it through. And it's this confusion of like, what do you mean people can be nuanced? What do you mean this wasn't the end? You know, I'd already emotionally prepared to cut you off. What is this? Why doesn't everyone think the same way as me? One account I read that was really profound was this person who, again, was on Reddit
或者想聚在一起谈谈。这种困惑就像是，你是什么意思，人们可以有多面性？你是什么意思，这不是结局？你知道，我已经做好了情感上的准备把你切断。这是什么？为什么不是每个人都和我以同样的方式思考？我读过的一篇非常深刻的报道是这个人，同样是在 Reddit 上
and was like genuinely seemed confused that someone who she had had an argument with wanted to repair the relationship. She was like, what do you mean? Surely this is all the evidence we need and that we require to know that this friendship isn't going to work out. Conflict is part of a relationship. But if you have this emotional instability and these previous experiences of being hurt or being let down,
并且似乎真的感到困惑，为什么一个她曾与之争吵过的人会想要修复这段关系。她说，你是什么意思？这肯定就是我们所需的所有证据，我们需要知道这段友谊是不会成功的。冲突是关系的一部分。但是如果你有这种情感不稳定以及以前受过伤或失望的经历，
well, of course, it's going to be a lot harder to tolerate. People who are actually the romantic partners of people with BPD often report really struggling sometimes with this cycle of closeness and conflict, feeling deeply loved one moment and painfully rejected the next. There was a 2014 study that looked at this specifically, the partners of people with BPD. And what they found was that a lot of these romantic partners reported an increased sense of hurt in the aftermath of arguments and an increased sense of caregiver burnout or caregiving anxiety. When you feel deeply personally responsible for someone else's emotions all of the time,
那么，当然，这会变得更难容忍。BPD 患者的浪漫伴侣经常报告说，有时很难应对这种亲密与冲突的循环，上一秒感觉被深深地爱着，下一秒又感到痛苦地被拒绝。2014年有一项专门研究这一点的研究，即 BPD 患者的伴侣。他们发现，许多这些浪漫伴侣报告说，在争吵之后受伤的感觉增加，照顾者倦怠或照顾焦虑的感觉增加。当你时刻对别人的情绪感到深深的个人责任时，
and that person is also, you know, a little bit difficult or impossible to predict, that takes its toll, it takes its toll on the other person, it takes its toll on the structure of the relationship as a whole. Parents of young adults or teenagers with BPD also report this feeling. There was another study, I think, in 2021 that looked at them as the, main relationship in the life of someone with BPD. And again, it's this weird, it's this weird difficulty of feeling helpless and guilty, but also angry, wanting to set boundaries, but also wanting to let this person be in control because that might be the best way to manage the situation.
而那个人又，你知道，有点难以相处或无法预测，这就会付出代价，这会对另一个人付出代价，这会对整个关系的结构付出代价。患有 BPD 的年轻成年人或青少年的父母也会报告这种感觉。我想2021年还有另一项研究将他们视为 BPD 患者生活中的主要关系。而且，这又是一种奇怪的、感到无助和内疚的奇怪困难，但也感到愤怒，想要设定界限，但也想让这个人掌控，因为这可能是管理情况的最佳方式。
As a result of this, which again, a lot of these people, actually all of them, they cannot control this amplified emotional reaction. But as a result of it, there is a huge link between BPD, and loneliness. Because of how individuals with this condition relate and interact with others, it is really common for people with BPD to self-isolate as the only appropriate reaction to these behavioral patterns that, number one, they don't want, but number two, they find themselves being unable to control. They don't actually want to hurt people. They don't actually want to have this repetitive relational pattern of loving someone intensely, trusting someone intensely, and then one thing going wrong and feeling like the world is splitting open.
由于这一点，同样，这些人中的许多人，实际上所有人，他们无法控制这种放大的情绪反应。但正因为如此，BPD 与孤独之间存在着巨大的联系。由于这种状况的个体与他人建立联系和互动的方式，BPD 患者进行自我隔离是非常常见的，这是对这些行为模式的唯一恰当反应，第一，他们不想要，第二，他们发现自己无法控制。他们其实不想伤害别人。他们其实不想有这种重复的人际关系模式，即强烈地爱一个人、强烈地信任一个人，然后一件事出错了，就觉得世界裂开了。
And so because they find it difficult to manage the emotional consequences of relationships, they just avoid relationships in general. Research shows that not only are people with BPD more likely to be lonely compared to the general population, but their social networks are often much smaller, much less diverse, also less satisfying. And maybe we could even trace this back to what we were talking about before with the suicidal ideation and behavior. Loneliness is of course going to be another factor. Not only can you not control your emotional state, you also don't get that same support socially that maybe you really need and that other people do receive. You know, I just, I can't imagine how
因此，由于他们发现很难处理人际关系的情感后果，他们干脆回避人际关系。研究表明，BPD 患者不仅比普通人更容易感到孤独，而且他们的社交网络通常更小、更多元化程度更低、也更不令人满意。也许我们甚至可以将其追溯到我们之前谈到的自杀意念和行为。孤独当然会是另一个因素。你不仅无法控制你的情绪状态，而且你也无法获得你可能真正需要并且其他人确实得到的社会支持。你知道，我只是，我无法想象那是多么
isolating that would feel. To want love and to want to be around people so badly. And to really love the depth and the intensity and beauty of relationships, but also know that there's a part of you that just can't handle it and just deciding to opt out. Like that's a crazy sacrifice and a crazy decision that people have to make. And this is the thing. For people with BPD, there is the stigma that they're. capacity to love is kind of broken, that they can't do it normally. That's not true. It's simply
孤立的感觉。非常渴望爱，渴望和人们在一起。并且真正热爱关系的深度、强度和美丽，但也知道你身上有一部分就是无法处理它，然后决定退出。这是一种疯狂的牺牲和人们不得不做出的疯狂决定。这就是事情所在。对于 BPD 患者来说，有一种污名，认为他们爱的能力有点破碎，他们无法正常做到这一点。这不是真的。它只是
tethered to fear in a way that I guess a lot of us don't really understand unless, of course, we're in it, unless we're experiencing it. Let's talk some more about the stigma around BPD since we've kind of gotten started on that now, because I do think it's one of the most stigmatized mental health diagnoses out there. Part of the stigma comes from a misunderstanding about the behaviours associated with BPD, particularly the intention of these behaviours. Outwardly, someone might appear to be doing things to get attention, to be manipulative, to be dramatic. A partner might, you know, this person might frantically call you or have these very intense emotional outburst and you might think that that's a control tactic.
与恐惧挂钩，以一种我想我们很多人除非身处其中、除非正在经历，否则真的无法真正理解的方式。让我们多谈谈围绕 BPD 的污名，既然我们已经开始谈论这个了，因为我确实认为它是现存最被污名化的心理健康诊断之一。部分污名来自于对与 BPD 相关的行为的误解，特别是这些行为的意图。在表面上，一个人可能看起来在做事情来引起注意、来操纵、来戏剧化。伴侣可能会，你知道，这个人可能会疯狂地给你打电话或有这些非常强烈的情感爆发，你可能会认为这是一种控制策略。
That I hate you, don't leave me experience. It, you know, it might not be manipulation. It actually rarely is manipulation in a calculated sense. It is just the only panicked way that someone with VPD can respond to a situation. They do not have the same emotional and interpersonal regulation skills that the, again, average person has. So they are not sitting there and thinking, well, if I react this way, I'm going to get a certain response. And even if they are, it's not because they want to necessarily hurt someone. They're just doing anything to get back to a place of emotional safety
那个我恨你，不要离开我的体验。它，你知道，可能不是操纵。在深思熟虑的意义上，它实际上很少是操纵。这只是 VPD 患者对某种情况做出反应的唯一恐慌方式。他们不像平均水平的人那样拥有相同的情感和人际交往调节技能。所以他们不是坐在那里想，如果我这样反应，我会得到某种回应。即使他们是，那也不是因为他们一定想伤害某人。他们只是在做任何事情来回到情绪安全的地方
within the relationship. It's a survival strategy. That push, pull, that I want to let you in, but I don't know how to, I don't want to be disappointed. It does cause them to do things that outwardly might seem really strange, but for them make perfect sense or don't make sense, but they feel like they have no control. Of course, I do think cultural representations only make matters worse. We've talked about some good representations. A lot of the stuff we see these days, all the characterizations of people with BPD online are less educational, less informative. And, you know, when you see social media or TV or movies frequently portray people with BPD, toxic exes or dangerous individuals, it reinforces this fear and this sense that they don't have
在关系之内。这是一种生存策略。那种推拉，那种我想让你进来，但我不知道该怎么做，我不想失望。它确实会导致他们做出在表面上看起来非常奇怪的事情，但对他们来说完全说得通，或者说不通，但他们觉得他们无法控制。当然，我确实认为文化表现只会使事情变得更糟。我们已经讨论了一些好的表现。我们这些天看到很多东西，网上对 BPD 患者的所有性格刻画都缺乏教育意义，信息量较少。而且，当你看到社交媒体、电视或电影频繁将 BPD 患者描绘成有毒的前任或危险的个人时，它会巩固这种恐惧和这种感觉，即他们没有
empathy when that's totally not what's going on here. I will say caveat here in some ways I do understand sometimes why people want to talk about it that way because that's their perception and that's their truth. Their truth was that they were in a relationship with someone who had this condition and they experienced things that really hurt them and they experience behaviors that maybe left them feeling very unstable and could be interpreted as dangerous. Two things can be true here. Someone can be experiencing a personality disorder. They really don't have a grasp of.
同理心，而这根本不是这里正在发生的事情。我要在这里打个预防针，在某些方面我确实理解为什么有时人们想那样谈论它，因为那是他们的看法，那是他们的真相。他们的真相是，他们曾与一个患有这种状况的人谈恋爱，他们经历了一些真正伤害他们的行为，他们经历的行为可能让他们感到非常不稳定，并可能被解释为危险的。这里有两件事可以同时成立。一个人可能正在经历一种人格障碍。他们真的无法掌控。
And that might not be entirely their fault. And someone else can equally be suffering from that same condition on the other end, on the kind of sharp, pointy end of the behaviours that the person with BP is using to protect themselves. So, again, it's complicated, it's nuanced, I think it's hard to talk about, because you want to validate someone's experience of what is, again, a diagnosable mental health disorder, but you also want to understand that, yeah, people do get hurt by these behaviors, whether intentionally or not.
这可能并不完全是他们的错。而另一个人同样可能在遭受完全相同的状况，处于由 BPD 患者用来保护自己的行为的尖锐、刺痛的一端。所以，再次强调，这很复杂，很有细微差别，我认为这很难谈论，因为你想确认某人对某种可诊断的心理健康障碍的经历，但你也想理解，是的，人们确实会被这些行为伤害，无论是有意还是无意。
The thing is, is that people with BPD are not sociopaths, they're not narcissists, they don't have those same, the same lack of empathy as you would maybe expect from someone who is deliberately manipulative. Maybe they have comorbidity, but it's not a significant level of them. So they get the shame. They understand it. They understand their erratic behaviors. They don't want to be like this. And that's really hard because that self-criticism and these misconceptions actually make them feel more isolated and hopeless, less likely to get help. Another thing we need to talk about, another layer of this actually comes from gendered assumptions around PPD. So something you may not know is that historically BPD has been diagnosed
问题是，患有边缘型人格障碍（BPD）的人不是反社会者，也不是自恋者，他们没有你可能期望的那种缺乏同理心，就像你对一个故意操纵他人的人所期望的那样。也许他们有共病，但并不是很显著的比例。所以他们会感到羞耻。他们理解这一点。他们理解自己的古怪行为。他们不想变成这样。这真的很艰难，因为这种自我批判和这些误解实际上让他们感到更加孤立和绝望，更不愿意寻求帮助。我们需要谈论的另一件事，这一现象的另一层原因实际上来自围绕PPD的性别假设。所以你可能不知道的是，历史上BPD被诊断出的情况
significantly more often in women. Some estimates suggest it's about 75% of diagnosed cases are female. And if we look back, this is basically reinforced this cultural stereotype that emotional intensity, volatility, relational sensitivity is inherently feminine or that women who express strong emotions are somehow hysterical, overly dramatic borderline. These stereotypes are really dangerous because they don't just influence some random person on the streets judgment. They shape clinical perception as well and we know this because of, again, those diagnosis rates. a woman who is emotional, anxious, having issues in their relationship prone to self-harm, they may be more quickly labeled as borderline, whilst a man with the same underlying issues
女性要多得多。一些估计表明，大约75%被确诊的病例是女性。如果我们回顾过去，这基本上强化了一种文化刻板印象，即情绪强度、易变性、关系敏感性本质上是女性化的，或者表达强烈情绪的女性在某种程度上是歇斯底里的、过于戏剧化的边缘人。这些刻板印象真的很危险，因为它们不仅会影响街头某个随机路人的判断。它们也塑造了临床认知，我们之所以知道这一点，同样是因为那些诊断率。一个情绪化、焦虑、关系出现问题且容易自残的女性，可能更快被贴上边缘型人格的标签，而一个有着同样潜在问题的男性
and patterns might be seen differently. And that's probably what's resulting in men being underdiagnosed, even when they meet the criteria for BPD. Why? Partly because the same way that an autism diagnosis has been set up to, catch more young boys due to their socialization. A BPD diagnosis has been set up to catch more women because of how they have been socialized. Men tend to externalize distress in ways that society and clinicians would interpret differently. Instead of expressing sadness or fear,
和模式可能会被区别对待。这可能就是导致男性被漏诊的原因，即使他们符合BPD的标准。为什么？部分原因就像自闭症诊断的建立是为了由于社交方式而捕捉更多年轻男孩一样。BPD诊断的建立是为了捕捉更多女性，因为她们的社会化方式。男性倾向于以社会和临床医生会有所不同解读的方式来外化痛苦。而不是表达悲伤或恐惧，
they might display anger or impulsivity or risk-taking behaviors or substance use. These expressions can lead clinicians to assign very different diagnoses, as we talked about before. A lot of people with BPD, get a lot of different labels before they find this final one that really does describe them. So for men, it might be antisocial personality disorder, anger management issues, conduct disorders. And that means that the treatment they receive only addresses the reactions or the outbursts rather than the cause. The result is, you know, what we know is a gendered blind spot. Women are overrepresented in statistics. So that means that we have a very limited way of seeing this disorder that has been influenced by gender and it means that the disorder has often been
他们可能会表现出愤怒、冲动、冒险行为或物质使用。正如我们之前所讨论的，这些表现在临床医生那里可能会导致完全不同的诊断。许多BPD患者在找到真正描述他们的最终诊断之前，会得到许多不同的标签。因此，对于男性来说，可能是反社会人格障碍、愤怒管理问题、品行障碍。这意味着他们接受的治疗只针对反应或爆发，而不是根源。其结果是，你知道的，我们所知的性别盲点。女性在统计数据中占比较高。这意味着我们对这种受性别影响的障碍的看法非常有限，这意味着这种障碍通常被
stigmatized for just meaning that someone overreacts or is labeled as manipulative, not to be trusted, whilst men are under-recognized and they go without support entirely. Here's the thing that we have not mentioned once, which now I'm realizing I probably should have mentioned it earlier, but BPD is treatable. For a long time, clinicians believed it wasn't. patients with BPD were seen as too difficult, too resistant, too uncooperative. We now know recovery or what they call remission from this disorder is not only possible, it is incredibly common, more so than what you are thinking.
污名化，仅仅意味着某人反应过度或被贴上爱操纵、不值得信任的标签，而男性则未被充分认识，完全得不到支持。这里有一件事我们一次都没有提到，我现在意识到我可能应该早点提到，那就是BPD是可以治疗的。很长一段时间里，临床医生认为它无法治愈。BPD患者被视为太难搞、太抗拒、不配合。我们现在知道，从这种障碍中恢复或所谓的缓解不仅是可能的，而且非常普遍，比你想象的还要普遍。
Incredibly common. So we are going to take a short break now. But when we return, I want to talk about that. I want to reveal why therapy for BPD is actually becoming. incredibly effective. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers,
非常普遍。所以我们现在要休息一会儿。但当我们回来时，我想谈谈这个。我想揭示为什么BPD的治疗实际上变得如此有效。所以请继续收听。2%。这是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、
researchers and other health and fitness experts and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
这就是I-Hart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Persent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日子的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84对我来说意义重大，不仅因为可卡因。我一整天都乐意谈论可卡因，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
所以我开始发现这里有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你说完那句话。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Pott. or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Pott或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth,
以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得做一个好人很重要，还是因为你害怕才做一个好人？
or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。和我一起，基尔·盖恩斯，我们在我的新播客《learn the hard way》中就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标进行真实的对话。
on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free. iHeartRadio app search Learn the Hard Way and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones.
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于 paternity 丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾。这开始了长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你对某人篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改测试了一次。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars. were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
这需要一群互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑爆炸了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over. until justice is served in Arizona.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对应有的后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。这还没结束，
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield.
直到正义在亚利桑那州得到伸张。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男性都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。
And in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
在这个新季的《女朋友》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得自己像是被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上。警察似乎并不在所以她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼不。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So let me throw some statistics at you hear from the National Institute of Health from 2012.
我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《女朋友》。相信我，宝贝。在IHart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。让我向你们介绍一下2012年美国国立卫生研究院的一些统计数据。
These results have been reaffirmed. Later on, I think in 2024, they did a follow-up study. They found that this hasn't changed a whole lot. In the study, they wanted to see if someone with BPD was put into an appropriate treatment environment, how would they do? and could they quote unquote recover? What they found was that 60% of borderline patients will achieve a recovery from borderline personality disorder if they go through treatment.
这些结果得到了再次确认。后来，我想是在2024年，他们做了一项后续研究。他们发现这并没有发生太大的变化。在这项研究中，他们想看看如果一个患有BPD的人被安置在适当的治疗环境中，他们会怎么样？他们能否所谓地康复？他们发现，如果接受治疗，60%的边缘型患者将实现从边缘型人格障碍中康复。
That number maybe even higher. There was one such intervention where there was a 99% remission rate, showing that of almost all of the mental health disorders out there, This one is actually one that responds to treatment very well. And how they kind of categorize remission is a lack of symptoms that create distress or cause problems socially, psychologically or physically. A lot of people will find that the older they get, the more symptoms will and can ease through getting therapy and through having good therapeutic approaches to what they're experiencing. The gold standard here is dialectical behavior therapy or DBT, which we mentioned earlier. I promised that we would come back to it and here we are.
这个数字甚至可能更高。曾有过这样一次干预，缓解率达到了99%，这表明在现有的几乎所有心理健康障碍中，这一种实际上是对治疗反应非常好的障碍。他们如何对缓解进行分类，即缺乏引起痛苦或在社会、心理或身体上造成问题的症状。很多人会发现，随着年龄的增长，通过接受治疗以及对他们所经历的事情采取良好的治疗方法，越来越多的症状将能够并且确实得到缓解。这里的黄金标准是辩证行为疗法或DBT，我们之前提到过。我承诺我们会回过头来谈论它，现在我们来了。
What makes DBT so effective is that it was designed specifically for what you might call an under-controlled personality type. Now, before this therapy, people really couldn't figure out what to do with BPD patients. And then this amazing woman came along and she invented this. And what she really realized was that people whose emotions are intense, whose emotions are quick to flare, hard to regulate, who are kind of maybe a little bit more socially abrasive at times, they need a different approach to therapy compared to the traditional methods of doing it.
DBT之所以如此有效，是因为它是专门针对你可能称之为控制不足的人格类型设计的。现在，在这项疗法出现之前，人们真的不知道该拿BPD患者怎么办。然后这个了不起的女性出现了，她发明了这个。她真正意识到的是，那些情绪强烈、情绪容易爆发、难以调节、有时甚至可能在社交上更具攻击性的人，与传统的治疗方法相比，需要一种不同的治疗方法。
And so the key thing about DBT is that it meets people with BPD where they're at. It doesn't try and force them to control or suppress their emotions or try to over-explain them or reappraise them the way that maybe other therapies do. It actually asks for people to live within it and with the emotions in a way that people talk about as being highly, highly effective. So it's built around four key skills or pillars. The first is mindfulness. You might hear the word mindfulness and be like, oh my God, can we? not talk about that anymore. And I get it. Like, I feel like mindfulness is this thing that gets thrown
所以DBT的关键在于，它在BPD患者所在的地方与他们相遇。它不会试图强迫他们控制或压抑自己的情绪，也不会试图过度解释或重新评估它们，就像其他疗法可能做的那样。它实际上要求人们生活在其中，并以一种人们认为高度高度有效的方式与情绪共存。所以它是围绕四个核心技能或支柱构建的。首先是正意。你可能会听到“正意”这个词，然后觉得，天哪，我们能别再谈这个了吗？我懂。就像，我觉得正意这个词被强加于
at any mental health problem. And it's like, well, have you tried mindfulness? Have you tried exercise? Have you tried this or that? And it's like, okay, I don't think sitting in a room and thinking about my thoughts for an hour or so is going to help me. But really what it's about is being grounded in the present moment. And that's something that you can control. And it's also about observing feelings without judgment. This is a very hard skill to develop. A lot of the time, we will feel a feeling and we either put it in the good or the bad category. Now, if you're someone who has these very polarized emotions, as is the case with BPD, where that's an even more sharper contrast, being able to just respect an emotion and not force
任何心理健康问题。感觉就像，好吧，你试过正意吗？你试过运动吗？你试过这个或那个吗？感觉就像，好吧，我不认为在一个房间里坐着想一个小时左右的想法会对我有帮助。但实际上，这是关于脚踏实地活在当下。这是你可以控制的事情。这也是关于在不评判的情况下观察感受。这是一项很难培养的技能。很多时候，当我们感觉到一种情绪时，要么把它归入好或坏的类别。现在，如果你是一个情绪非常极端的人，就像BPD的情况一样，那是一种更鲜明的对比，能够只尊重一种情绪而不强迫
your way or push against it or try and force your way through it is incredibly helpful. Then there is distress tolerance, so supporting the individual so that they can survive a crisis without worsening a situation, learning how to cope with pain without acting impulsively, then comes emotional regulation, identifying patterns, learning strategies to reduce our vulnerability to extreme emotional swings. There's this one strategy I heard of that's like the zoo strategy, or the aquarium strategy, I can't remember what it's called, either the aquarium or the zoo strategy, and it's like watching your emotions like they're behind a glass,
你的方式或反对它，或者试图强行通过它，是极其有帮助的。接下来是痛苦耐受力，支持个人以便他们能够在不恶化情况的情况下度过危机，学习如何在不采取冲动行动的情况下应对痛苦，然后是情绪调节，识别模式，学习减少我们对极端情绪波动脆弱性的策略。我听说过这样一个策略，就像动物园策略，或者水族馆策略，我不记得它叫什么了，不管是水族馆还是动物园策略，就像看着你的情绪一样，就像它们在玻璃后面，
in your pain and you can stay there for as long as you want and you can watch how your emotions want you to react or where they're moving in your body and then you can just walk away when you're done observing and when you get bored of that emotion. And finally, there's interpersonal effectiveness. Learning how to communicate needs clearly. Set boundaries. Maintain healthy relationships. Not lash out. Not immediately assume abandonment. That's something that a lot of people with DBT have not always, sorry, with BPD, oh my God, so many Bs, T's and Ds and P's. That's something that people with BPD haven't always been taught. This is a really, really powerful therapy. I feel like I've said that a million times. One of its unique strengths is the emphasis
在你的痛苦中，你想待多久就待多久，你可以看着你的情绪希望你如何反应，或者它们在你的身体里如何移动，然后当你观察完，当你对那种情绪感到厌烦时，你就可以走开。最后，是人际交往效能。学习如何清晰地表达需求。设定界限。维持健康的关系。不要发飙。不要立即假设被抛弃。这是很多DBT患者没有一直，抱歉，BPD患者，天哪，有太多的B、T、D和P了。这是BPD患者并不总是被教导的东西。这是一个非常非常强大的疗法。我觉得我已经说过一百万次了。它独特的优势之一是强调
on validation. So it really acknowledges the reality of someone's emotional pain. And it's not sitting there and being like, it's not asking someone to change overnight. It's not asking someone to change overnight. It's not asking someone to not have these feelings. It's just asking for them to interact with them in a different way in a way that's actually maybe not going to work for everyone, but for people with BPD, it really does. Another approach, another evidence-based approach, I should say, is structured clinical management or SCM. This was developed in the UK. As you can imagine, DBT, incredibly time intensive, incredibly expensive. And basically they wanted a more generalist alternative to such a therapy. Research has shown SCM is that effective alternative.
确认。所以它真正承认了某人情感痛苦的现实。它并不是坐在那里说，它不要求某人在一夜之间改变。它不要求某人在一夜之间改变。它不要求某人没有这些情绪。它只是要求他们以一种不同的方式与这些情绪互动，这种方式可能并不适合所有人，但对于BPD患者来说，确实如此。另一种方法，我应该说是另一种基于证据的方法，是结构化临床管理或SCM。这是在英国开发的。你可以想象，DBT非常耗时，非常昂贵。基本上他们想要这种疗法的更通用的替代方案。研究表明，SCM就是那种有效的替代方案。
At its core, this is about structure, consistency, and support. As we've heard today, many people with BPD experience chaos in their relationships and in their daily lives. So having a reliable professional who provides clear expectations, who is there as a consistent contact, who can literally just provide you with practical guidance, can be professional. stabilizing. It's like having a buddy. It offers really regular, reliable support, psychoeducation, and basically someone who is like a sounding board when your emotions are making your thoughts very loud or making it, making you think that a certain reaction is appropriate when it just might not be. Really what this provides is predictability. For people whose early
归根结底，这关乎结构、一致性和支持。正如我们今天听到的那样，许多患有边缘型人格障碍的人在人际关系和日常生活中都会经历混乱。因此，有一个可靠的专业人士，能够提供明确的期望，作为持续联系人存在，并且能够实实在在地为你提供实际指导，这可能具有专业上的稳定作用。这就像拥有一个伴侣。它提供非常规律、可靠的支持、心理教育，基本上，当你的情绪让你的想法变得非常大声，或者让你认为某种反应是合适的而实际上可能并非如此时，有一个人可以充当倾诉对象。这真正提供的是可预测性。对于那些早期
environments were unpredictable or invalidating, simply having like a clinician or a trusted individual who consistently listens, who provides guidance, who doesn't withdraw in moments of crisis can be just like the can be it. That can be the thing that you need. It's incredibly affirming. Although like the skills these kinds of treatments teach are so valuable, it's really about how they can start to create that consistency for themselves and how they can basically learn in a non-avoidant way that someone leaving them, someone being mad at them, a relationship not working is not the end of the world. They can trust in themselves to survive. Again, the prognosis is really, really good. And that's what makes it hard to hear about the
环境不可预测或经常被否定的群体来说，仅仅拥有一个持续倾听、提供指导、在危机时刻不会退缩的临床医生或值得信赖的人，就可以成为关键所在。这可能就是你需要的那种支持。这具有令人难以置信的肯定作用。尽管这类治疗所教授的技巧非常有价值，但这其实关乎他们如何开始为自己创造这种一致性，以及他们如何基本上以一种不逃避的方式去学习：有人离开他们，有人生他们的气，一段关系行不通，并不是世界末日。他们可以相信自己能够挺过去。再次强调，预后真的非常好。这也是为什么听到有关
high rate of distress and the high suicide rates and the high self-harm rates to do with BPD. because it is so misunderstood because people don't get a label, because they perhaps don't know this information, there is this whole like suffer in silence. If I talk about it, someone's going to immediately characterize me as this kind of person. This is just something I have to get over kind of mentality. And I hope this episode is kind of lessened that for someone a little bit. So they understand that actually with the right people, there won't be stigma. and it's really like building a skill.
边缘型人格障碍的高痛苦率、高自杀率以及高自残率会让人感到难以接受。正因为这种疾病被如此严重地误解，因为人们没有得到明确的标签，因为他们可能不了解这些信息，所以才存在这种整体默默忍受的现象。如果我谈论它，别人会立刻把我归为那种人。这只是一种我必须挺过去的心理。我希望这期节目能稍微减轻某人的这种心理负担。这样他们就会明白，实际上在合适的人面前，是不会存在污名化的，这真的就像是在培养一种技能。
You put the time in, you put the effort in, you can experience a different way of relating to people that you really want to love and be close to and of relating to yourself. What looks like chaos for a lot of people in these situations is usually just pain. What looks like manipulation is usually just desperation. And what looks like hopelessness is in reality, like something that you can help yourself with. Like there is, there are so many stories of change and transformation in this space.
只要你付出时间和努力，你就能体验到一种完全不同的与人相处的方式——与那些你真正想要去爱和亲近的人相处，以及与自己相处的方式。在这些情况下，对许多人来说看似混乱的东西，通常只是痛苦。看似操纵的行为，通常只是绝望。而看似绝望的事情，在现实中其实是你可以通过自身努力去改善的。在这个领域里，有太多关于改变和转型的故事。
I will say if you are a romantic partner of someone with BPD, maybe that's why you're listening. And I'm sure you can understand all this. You can have empathy and compassion for this person and still realize you may not want to be with them. I've kind of circled this matter cautiously throughout this episode. Abandonment is such a big issue for people with BPD. But something I've always believed is that no one is owed a relationship. just because of what they're enduring or going through.
我想说，如果你是边缘型人格障碍患者的浪漫伴侣，也许这就是你收听的原因。我相信你能理解这一切。你可以对这个人抱有同理心和同情心，但同时也能意识到，你可能并不想和他们在一起。在整期节目中，我一直谨慎地探讨这个话题。被抛弃对边缘型人格障碍患者来说是一个巨大的问题。但我一直坚信的一点是，没有人仅仅因为他们正在忍受或经历什么，就理所当然地应该拥有某段关系。
And you aren't obligated to stay with someone when things are dysfunctional and when they haven't perhaps gotten the help that they need yet. And it is available to them. Even if they have limited control over this reaction, it doesn't mean that you have to be there to bear the brunt of it. You know, this is what we define as a personality disorder after all. And regardless of all the really positive statistics we have about remission, maybe at the of the day, your personalities just don't align and the condition is just part of that.
当事情陷入混乱，而他们可能还没有获得所需帮助时，你并没有义务留在某人身边。尽管这种帮助对他们来说是触手可及的。即使他们对这种反应的控制力有限，也不意味着你必须去承受它带来的冲击。毕竟，这就是我们所定义的人格障碍。抛开所有关于病情缓解的极佳统计数据不谈，也许到头来，你们的人格就是不合，而这种状况只是其中的一部分。
They might just need to find their person the same way that we all do. So if you are also listening to this thinking, how do I manage this incredibly emotionally complex relationship with someone who's afraid of being abandoned but I don't want to be with them anymore, approach it with a lot of kindness, see if you can maybe get them some help. Maybe this isn't the right time. maybe they do need to get treatment and know that the reaction they have is not always a reflection of you and that you are allowed to make the best choice in your situation. You know, this is a very complicated condition that's confusing, even for those who have
他们可能只是需要找到属于他们的人，就像我们所有人一样。因此，如果你在听的时候也在想：“我该如何处理这段情绪极其复杂的关系？对方害怕被抛弃，但我又不想再和她在一起了”，那么请带着极大的善意去对待，看看能否帮他们寻求一些帮助。也许现在还不是合适的时机，也许他们确实需要接受治疗，并且要明白他们的反应并不总是你的写照，你有权在自己的处境中做出最好的选择。你知道，这是一个非常复杂的状况，令人困惑，甚至对那些
been experiencing it and living it for decades. So I just want to say there are still a lot of things we don't understand about this. Perhaps there will one day be a whole manual and guidebook for navigating this kind of like maze that is operating in the mind of everybody, but specifically the maze in the mind of people with BPD. But until then, I think it's just good to have empathy for the things that we don't understand and the things that we don't know. And empathy for you, if you're experiencing BPD, for living in a brain that it's probably very different to everyone else's. And I can imagine it's kind of confusing sometimes to really want to be able to respond or behave in the way that
已经经历并生活其中数十年的人来说也是如此。所以我想说，关于这种状况，我们仍然有很多不了解的地方。也许有一天，会有一本完整的手册和指南，用来指引我们穿梭于这种迷宫——在每个人的大脑中运作的迷宫，尤其是边缘型人格障碍患者大脑中的迷宫。但在那之前，我认为对我们不理解和不知道的事情保持同理心是件好事。如果你正经历边缘型人格障碍，对生活在一个可能与其他人截然不同的大脑中的自己保持同理心也是件好事。我可以想象，有时候你非常希望能像其他人那样做出反应或表现，却又不知该如何是好，这一定让人感到很困惑。
others are and just not knowing how. So I'm sending you a lot of love. I hope that this has been informative. I hope that you've gotten a good introduction. Yeah, and that things change for you if you want them to and that you find some kind of hope at the end of the tunnel. Thank you again for listening. If you have made it this far, leave a little emoji down below. What am I going to do my emoji of? Guys, I always get this far and I forget maybe like a little star. I don't know. I'm feeling a star emoji today. So I know that you've made it this far. I want to thank our researcher Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode. As a reminder, there will be resources down below. I highly advised that you go and check them out if this episode resonated with you and if
所以我向你们发送许多爱。希望这期节目对你们有所帮助。希望你们获得了一个很好的开端。是的，希望如果你们愿意的话，事情会为你发生改变，并且能在隧道的尽头找到某种希望。再次感谢大家的收听。如果你听到了这里，请在下方留下一个小表情。我要用什么表情呢？伙计们，我每次到这里都会忘，也许用一个小星星吧。我不知道，我今天感觉想用一个星星表情。这样我就知道你听到了这里。我要感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Liby Colbert）对本期节目的贡献。提醒一下，下方会提供相关资源。如果这期节目引起了你的共鸣，或者
you want to learn more or if you just need some additional help. Make sure you're following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Almost forgot my own Instagram handle. That's been embarrassing. and that you are following along on Apple, Spotify, IHartRadio, Tidal, wherever you are listening. And give us a five-star review if you related or felt seen by this episode. Until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange
你想了解更多信息，或者只是需要一些额外的帮助，我强烈建议你去查看一下。确保在Instagram上关注我们，账号是That Psychology Podcast。差点忘了我自己的Instagram账号，真尴尬。并且要在Apple、Spotify、iHeartRadio、Tidal或任何你收听播客的地方进行关注。如果你对这期节目深有同感或从中看到了自己的影子，请给我们一个五星好评。我们下期再见，请注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再次交流。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们奇怪的
modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
现代世界中培养抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信植物油本身具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。即TWO%。可在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上轻拍小吉姆（Lil' Kim）胸部的那一幕吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人的时候。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out. on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小吉姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代可卡因泛滥的节目。坦白讲，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
我随时准备聊聊当年的可卡因，只是想让大家知道。我是说，马克，这是我们第二集讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病这个话题摆在了桌面上。谢谢你帮我把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
是的。对我而言，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却仍在追逐。我们甚至不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions. bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies.
因为人们总是在计分板上盯着比分。生活变成了关于赢和输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），是因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。和我——基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了其中明显的矛盾之处。
in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used
在她的故事中。这开启了一场长达数年的诉讼战，旨在证明真相。你曾经两次篡改过某个人的这项测试，对吗？我只篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破解了这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了
for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格（Greg）、一个女同性恋、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的大脑都要炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被正式指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
规则一，千万别惹乡村女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·西恩菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在这个全新季的《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一下。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no, I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上。警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼去吧，我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。请收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness,
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度的科学、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed.
体能训练以及在我们奇怪的现代世界中培养抗压能力。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。即TWO%。可在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己动手。我发誓。
I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。请收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it
在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和说是个大日子。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的
with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast,
欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话——这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一身铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客收听《Learn the Hard Way》，
or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
或在任何你获取播客的地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾经两次篡改过这个特定的测试，对吗？我只篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格、一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a Love Trapped podcast on the EyeHour Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的大脑都要炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终要承担后果了。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。